this is the song we start with because
it makes me feel
good the only way they're going to hear
you though is if you pick up the
microphone I'm not a pro like his first
I'm not a pro my first Freddy Prince
Junior's first time in front of a
microphone everybody that's right you
didn't know you had to pick it up at
work first year rookie but I'll still
get Rookie of the Year I'll still get
there I a back for a a what's that
called a Lou a what a live a what you
know that microphone they put on your oh
is that what they call him it's not Al
Alo seems French just call it a
mic I never met any french sound guys
you know they're all from like Scarsdale
oh Pierre doesn't he doesn't Mike you up
I met Pierre oh Pier's good I like it he
goes up the front of your shirt with eye
contact I only know Mike and John that's
it Pier will give you eye contact I
don't want eye contact on tickles your
belly button I don't want belly button
he goes one knuckle deep do you no
that's the worst costume Ward drobe
person ever you don't want Pier to go
one knuckle deep I want no Knuckles deep
I want no depth can I tell you not too
long ago I was doing a this they don't
make music like this anymore they try it
just doesn't
work no they just don't okay um you know
I had a uh I had a mik guy who always
when he put you know he was like I'm
going to run in my hand up the front of
your shirt yeah but he went Palm forward
Palm the skin you know what I mean
instead of usually you get the back of
the skin he went Palm forward and I was
like and he always did you have a
six-pack then yeah there you go Bo but
still no that's why he liked the feel of
a washboard from when he was a child
doing laundry on the in Montana on the
lawn but wouldn't you rather have him
say I this is my theory on all that
don't be sneaky because sneaky I know
it's not that sneaky just say hey I'm
going to put this mic cuz I always look
at you and they go go I'm going to put
my hand up the front of your shirt yeah
but if you follow that with and I'm
going to turn my hand over so I can feel
your abs at least it would be less
creepy to me I'd be like no okay no you
would give him an insta no and that's
why he can't be that direct it has to be
more passive and just hey is he going to
say no he's not cuz when I was 12 years
old I did that to girls when I was
trying to fill them up those girls it's
just the 12-year-old approach to to
sixpacks oh yeah uh yeah I dated Serena
Williams when I was in fifth grade there
was this girl Stephanie
I forget she was in fifth grade and she
was in sixth grade yeah so I was dating
an older woman nice but so the big thing
was how am I going to let her talk her
into letting me it was going up the back
of her shirt oh you were going for the
bra well just the back of the shirt just
to get some want FL because in fifth
sixth grade it was it was not well back
I mean I gu I went for it I'm not going
to lie touch titties in sixth grade I
went I went for it man you you I went
back the shirt like a I thought I was a
[__] man bro I was girl in the first
grade I I hope somehow someone knows
Katie Cochran from monzano Day School in
aluer New Mexico she had short hair way
before short hair was cool way before
Charlie's Throne was doing it and we
were playing boys chase girls and I
caught her and she Heisman the kiss and
I was I like was like what you're first
grade yeah this is first grade and she
ran off again I caught her again she
wouldn't kiss me so I I had these sesame
Street shoelaces I took him out my shoes
I caught her again and I tied her to the
tree and I smooched her I know this is
against the law but it was you know 1980
I'm trying to think if you can prosecute
you better do you know I'm sorry Katie I
should have said a different name um so
the the bell rang and I freaked out cuz
I knew I was in trouble so I just ran I
ran in the class you left tied to the
tree yeah and the classroom was only
like 20 yards from the tree and so we
had this teacher name was Mrs S and uh
she goes where's ktie she was British
and uh where's ktie and you hear her
screaming outside like help and my head
is just on the desk in first grade like
five sixy old shame already oh you knew
[__] was bad oh she comes in with the
shoelaces and she just goes who are
these and I literally was like I look
down and I'm just
like
yeah walked my ass straight to the br's
office just knew I was donez my mom was
like what on Earth have you done for she
was it was a private school where they
paddled like they paddled they wanted to
my mom didn't let him only she was
allowed to smash on me did ever at the
school you went to you could paddle oh
yeah man they cut holes in the board to
cut down on a wind resistance and so it
whistled as it was coming towards your
ass I don't know if it whistled but it
hurt did you get paddled yeah I got
paddled when my mom had enough yeah okay
so what ages is this school um this was
a 1 through 8th grade and you could pass
P all the way through up to eighth grade
and who did the paddling uh his name was
Mr mcran he was the fizzed teacher but
once freshman year wait the fizzed
teacher got to do it yeah Mr mcran yeah
but once those boys were big enough to
fight back they didn't allow paddling
Cuz Mr mcran was small and a freshman
would have been like yo in in New Mexico
we had like big Native American dudes
that are like dog I drink on the
weekends man like they're not gonna
they're not gonna have Mr mcgan wait a
second so I'm I I I obvious I went to a
public school we did not have paddling
we people got beat up in bathrooms we
got beat up plenty but wait so how did
they decide a couple questions how do
they decide how many paddles you get
Okay and like is was there like was
there a certain rule like you didn't go
well if you tie a girl up with shoelaces
let's check the chart do you know what I
mean no so oh the chart that's 74
paddles so two and be ass uh no you had
your pants right uh so out or not my
dick remained in okay so two lunch you
get a lunch detention for any trouble
regardless of what it was two lunch
detentions equal to morning detention
morning detention meant you came in
before school and you did ran laps you
did duck walks across the field right
all kinds of bull crap three morning
detentions and you got paddled and I
never went to any of those [__]
things so I had a lot of paddles on the
record but I just wouldn't show so when
I finally transferred to public school
they weren't going to release my records
until I took a whooping and my mom
literally was like you hit my child and
I will shoot you now this is the ' 80s
my mom's brother was a Vietnam vet he
didn't go through customs on the way
back from the war she had an Armory okay
she would have they knew she would have
they handed my files over to laqua high
school and life was good did you that is
insane I wonder if they still paddle
there you think they I don't think so
it's got to be illegal it's now it's got
to be people freak out on that stuff I
mean my mom used to make me pick my belt
be like go pick your belt and that meant
you were your ass was kicked um which
belt did you like to pick did you was a
thinner one or thicker one I mean at a
certain point the walk is worse than the
whooping so small ones hurt more uh than
than the wide ones but it doesn't like
no it's all pretty terrible isn't it
yeah a nine and a 10 is still CRA it's
still a it's still an assass weapon wait
okay do you all right because I did not
get
belt but I'm not opposed to people
spanking their kids yeah okay um did you
did that like how does that translate to
you parenting now just out of curiosity
I have never I know you don't take the
belt I've never would never like I'm all
about trying to talk and not lose my P
look I before is that because of your
experience no it's a level it's just a
level of patience my mom didn't have a
husband like he killed himself it she
was a wreck after that and oh yeah she
had to raise a son that looked a lot
like him and had the same name so her
patience was like at a two yeah so it
was like here's a a punch for what
you're about to do today that I'm sure
I'll get a phone call about at noon so
that was more what she had to do like
were you an unruly kid um prepubescence
yeah cuz I every kid had a pops but me
and kids started asking me questions
about my dad and I didn't know for those
who didn't know like my pops was Freddy
PS he was a comedian in the 70s and he
shot himself in the head um on January
28th which was my mom's freaking
birthday I did not know that yeah and
and he he passed on so he had the number
one show in America in the 70s it was
called Chico and the Man and so all
these kids that I went to school with
their parents were madwire into his life
and death yeah and so kids were asking
me a lot of questions that my mom didn't
know how to prepare me for um I was
getting in a lot of fights I was getting
in a lot of trouble and she just didn't
she didn't know how to do anything other
than like damn it stop and then that
would wake me up a little and when I got
older and those didn't work um she even
kicked me in the balls one time um did
that work I tried to no sell it but to
no avail you can't no sell that I tried
to be like Andre the Giant in those old
Japan matches where he just let be like
no bro I'm way bigger F you but instead
it was like great reference dude what a
great [__] ref I used to work for
Vince McMahon bro I know wrestling
you stood there for a second you're like
I'm going to be able to ride this out
and then about 3 seconds in you're like
no I'm not I'm like you ever watch
hockey and you see the guy get checked
and he bounces off the wall and he has
like two good strides and then it's like
there we go boom that's what happened
that's what happened that always is like
I when you see video I'm like how did
that dude walk out of that car crash and
he walks he takes four steps and he's
like I'm alive I didn't I'm going to
fall down now yeah exactly there was an
old fight between Zab Judah and zoo and
they were both really popular boxers at
the time and Zab Judah gets beat in this
fight he takes this hook and he his knee
touches the canas and he jumps up as
quick as he can to show The Ref that
he's okay and he's staggering all over
and the ref's trying to call the fight
and he goes I'm okay and he throws this
huge left hook and just knocks himself
out and falls on the ground talking yeah
and it's like those are the moment and
the ball shot was that it was the No No
Yeah you know I'm going to go ahead and
tip my hat to you on this one you got me
on this one you got so after that she
she shipped me out west and I got to
meet my my uncle Rond DeBlasio who just
had his uh 84th birthday he was my dad's
manager uh he was Richard prior's
manager he was Prince's manager and he
was just this epic well of knowledge and
he was the first guy to really break
down not how my dad died
but I almost cursed but why but [__]
why um did that help you yeah um he
walked me in front of marily and Rose
house and told me the story about
Marilyn Monroe and and like the tragedy
of it he lived like two houses away from
her cuz he was rich as hell yeah and uh
so he's telling me the story and then he
connects Marilyn Monroe to my father by
talking about you know stars that shine
too bright and they went and he knew
that I liked space and I used to build
rockets and stuff like that and he you
did yeah I was really into science and
Dungeons and Dragons and martial arts
that was my whole that was my whole life
when I was a kid and he he compared my
father and Maryland to a supernova when
a star goes Supernova and uh and it
explodes and I remember like how old
were you I was uh 12 I was 12 years old
no 11 years off I was getting ready to
go into sixth grade and uh it was that
summer vacation and I remember
everything kind of clicking and then he
just legit took me to the Improv I was
11 12 at midnight and getting to see
like Bobby Slayton tell me stories about
my dad and be like oh you're [__] dad
man the son of a [__] you'd always take
too long and I'd never get on stage but
I loved that Charles Fleer who was the
voice of Roger fraking Rabbit opened for
my father on his first Comedy album and
and I'm meeting the voice of Roger
Rabbit I'm 11 okay it's a big deal the r
rabbit is a huge deal and he hates the
rabbit and he did it for me and he tells
me this story he says uh he goes uh you
know I opened for your father Mr Chow in
in Chicago in 19 that sounds like Peter
folk but they kind of sound the same
it's pretty close by the way nobody
listening knows either voice so you oh
so he's Chinese
um and is your dad walks into the
dressing room remember I'm 11 and uh he
comes in and he says hey uh Charlie you
think you have a bigger dick than me I'm
11 and he goes he goes I look at him and
I go yeah probably and he goes well let
me see it and he says well I'm not gay
so I pulled it out and he looks at and
he goes nope mine's bigger and he walked
out of the [__] room I'm 11 years old
and this guy just made my father the
coolest dude in every story that I heard
about my dad up until that point was oh
my God I loved your dad so much he was
magic right and that don't mean [__] to
me like I have I had no memories of my
father I the only memories I can get are
if you met him and I can steal one from
you so it fills in the blanks a little
more yeah so that takes your father away
from Superhero status and just makes him
this threedimensional character instead
of a comic book character which is what
he was to me for so many years um is
that when you moved out here when you
were when you were 11 hold on yeah
listen I I'm going to do something
incredibly unprofessional what I started
with no mic yes but my everybody
listening knows my son Jacob he needs
he okay I need to call okay we're gonna
put him on speaker does he want the
Roger Rabbit voice he's at the dentist
right now hey Dad hi buddy you're on
speaker and we're doing the podcast and
Freddy's here too so go ahead what's oh
well it's kind of it's kind of
concerning like the health insurance
card for the dentist I can just do it
when we get back so you guys at the end
of the podcast well what is it something
that you still going to be able to go to
the dentist no I can still come to the
dentist yeah like I'll still get the
cleaning and what not I'll just bring
bring you back a phone number that you
have to call and then they'll ask you a
couple questions about the insurance and
whatnot so they can pay for it go for
the Laughing Gas sounds good yeah make
sure you get laughing gas that's
important okay I'll make sure all right
buddy love you home
bye I saw my future that's my
buddy um what when did you move out here
how old were you um I was back and forth
from age 11 to 18 and then in 1994 I
moved out here full-time and did you
okay because right
now you you don't act as much as you
used to and that's conscious you're done
yeah did you start acting because you
thought that's what you were supposed to
do it was exactly what I was told to do
yeah so when I was six when I was 16 my
grandfather got rest his soul um was a
little bit racist Just Mine by the way
listen mine too my grandparents you know
one of my brothers only ever dated black
girls and okay and
so my grandmother at one point referred
to her in Boston uh she lived in Florida
at the time okay but she was referred to
her referred to a black person as
colored yes and I was like Nana that's
not okay and in her mind that was the
nice thing that was the nice thing to
say to not racist she would even say I
didn't say and then she said the N word
I'm like yeah neither one of those yeah
how about never say that how about
neither one of those or good but in
their brain right isn't that different
generation man they were all a little
bit racist even when they didn't think
they were being a little bit racist they
were being a lot [__] racist a lot
effing racist yeah you can swear I keep
forgetting I'm I'm a rookie St I told
you we're halfway through the first game
um I'll have a good at bat man it's
coming it's coming so you got into it
because you feel like that that is what
you were yeah what my grandfather when I
was 16 years old got cancer and uh and
couldn't fight it for very long how do
you deal with so much loss before the
age of [__] 18 I didn't until I was
like 30 it really
like like it it drove every choice I
made like I when you're a junior it's
hard enough okay because you're
basically a statue built to honor that
which walked before you um I had never
thought of that before it's weird man
it's every Junior I talk to was like
dude oh my God I'm like yeah right um
but uh you know my grandfather he he was
croaking and he was on hospice care and
my my grandmother said uh you know papa
wants to go and speak with you and I I I
went in his room and he would call me
fed which is fedo fed Italian for Freddy
right and he says uh in Italian he says
Fe did you did you clean your room today
and I said see papa see and he says in
English English he says I'm so proud of
you and I'm 15 16 I don't know what that
mean I'm like I clean my [__] room
yeah yeah yeah I do that a lot by the
way yeah I'm I'm pretty good kid like
what the [__] I play Nintendo games it's
easy to clean up easy and uh in the same
breath he takes my hand and he strong as
hell like I never beat him in arm
wrestling ever and I tried from like age
of like that old man strength is is
bizarre it was ridiculous and he holds
my hand he goes you know your now I have
to cuss he goes you know your father
really [__] things up and it's up to
you to fix it and an hour later he was
is
dead for real yo that is not like yeah
but how do I fix
it for real sound like him saying the
secret to life for real man so it was
when I first moved out here what a mind
[__] that fear is a big motivator and
and fear of of failing what he needed
and fear of letting my my mother down
who was against me coming out how did
you interpret that your grandfather
thought you needed to fix it by by by
taking his legacy to a different level
by when you heard his name the first
thing you heard was suicide right and
drugs and he had all these like amazing
they're horrible but in hindsight
amazing awesome affairs with like Pam
Greer Andel Welsh and Rachel W Joanna
Kars from C pays when she was a smoking
hot Dancer off Broadway oh let me tell
you this story I I did a I always know
when one of these old school actresses
[__] my father
because and there have been a lot of
them all right I'm only saying the names
of the women who have spoken about it
okay okay um cuz they all say hi to me
different when they meet me when I just
meet some old school actor I met like
time daily and she goes oh hi it's so
nice to meet you and she has like rose
pedal lenses on literally and speaks
that way as well and then you meet like
Pam Greer and she's like oh hi nice to
meet you and I'm like oh you guys [__]
yeah um and she wrote about in her book
so I'm doing a
pilot the the guy married my wife and I
um because her mom wanted it Jewish and
my mom wanted it Catholic so we had our
friend we did the same thing we had our
friend who got ordained online he was
just a gay choreographer be our priest
to kind of f you both of them we did we
did the same you got to we're modern
people you know we got to make sure it's
about us and not something else um so he
directed this pilot and Joanna Kerns was
in it and I go into the trailer and it's
just her and as soon as I see her if if
you had a video cast I would do the face
facial expression that she did but it
literally was like and her eyes got
really big and so before she spoke I was
like they
[__] and so I sit down and she said hi
I'm Joan I go hi Joan I'm Freddy Prince
Jr nice to meet you and she goes uh you
know I met your father and I'm like yeah
I'm assuming I bet you did and she tells
me this story and I I'll I'll share it
with you so my old man was on a date
with her and Pam Greer at the same time
and they were at a restaurant in in both
out on it yeah and they both said yeah
he was a pimp man he was like 62 and a
half had the the magn pi mustache that
mustache by the way was very real and
his hair was F hair was on point dude
the hair was on point and men would wear
platforms so they could be as tall as
him like Tony Orlando you tiny fool um
but he was doing comedy at my dad's
funeral so I can crack jokes on him was
he oh yeah yeah yeah so my dad's on this
date and they and Richard PRI calls the
restaurant and says uh hey I'm having a
party Fred come over bring the girls
with you you're not bad with voices
buddy I just want you to know you're I I
do I do a Star Wars cartoon and I work
with like all these like voice Legends
and I just asked him to do like I met
the guy who does Winnie the Pooh his
name's Jim Cummings and I'm like hey man
can you do this Snoop Dog rap for me as
in Winnie the Pooh and he'll do it now I
can't do Winnie the Pooh but when you
hang around these guys you can do bad
versions of all the Impressions they do
so all mine are just crappy versions so
Richard calls a restaurant come on over
and my dad brings both the ladies over
only Richard wasn't having on a party he
got a hold of one of my dad's old
Playboy Radio recordings and comedians
used to go on there in the 70s and do
like an hour just like on a mic on for
the radio show and my dad didn't like
the set that he did it was something
that it was only like 15 20 minutes and
he just didn't like the jokes and
Richard got it and when they came in
there's nobody there there's no party
it's just Richard with the tape and he's
playing it because he was in love with
Pam Greer and uh he's like look you
ain't funny [__] talking all
this [__] and my dad's like yo man you
better give me that tape and uh and
she's telling me the story and I'm
sitting back and at a certain point I'm
I'm realizing this is the best story
that anyone has ever told me about my
father and I've heard a bunch um and so
he's still talking trash my dad you
better give me that taper he goes I
ain't giving you [__] [__] he's
way bigger than Richard Pryor oh yeah
yeah yeah and my dad used to Sparrow
Muhammad Ali and so is that true yeah we
have a towel with Ali's blood on it I'll
tell you that story if you want yeah so
my dad jumps over the table and Joan
Kerns is telling me this punches Richard
yeah grabs a tape takes Pam leaves her
and splits as a consolation prize no he
just knew it would make Richard angrier
if he took Pam so I told I asked you I
said what did you do she said I got him
a towel and he called me a cab and then
cussed me out for no reason and I
left and I was sitting there going like
amazing the [__] that's yeah and do
these stories they help you even at this
point do they help you now I love I love
it I met like when I worked for Vince
McMahon at
WWE um we did uh me and this other guy
pitched an old school night where they'd
wear the old powder blue tuxedos we got
Jesse The Body and Vince to even
commentate a match and like we did all
the and we brought old school wrestlers
back like Sergeant Slaughter and this
one dude where's Ivan puty we didn't
bring Ivan I want to know where i a p
he's got to be 87 years old right now I
know but I don't want him to work and
get hurt we had uh we had this wrestler
named Alberto Del Rio whose father uh
and Uncle were both famous luchadors and
the WWE had one and his name was Chavo
classic and we had Chavo like drive him
out and this fresh ass Low Rider and
backstage I'm telling Chavo how the
segment's going to go and and he goes
hey man I met your father one time and
I'm like oh word I go yeah tell me he
goes do you mind if I tell you the story
he goes there's kind of drugs involved I
go no man it's okay I I understand it
was the 70s he goes yeah it was he goes
man he goes I was working a match in
Chicago he goes I was with you Frank
Sinatra and the Italian mob and I've
never got that high of cocaine in my
life and I literally was sitting there
like
and Vince is to my left waiting for me
to like pitch this guy a segment and
Vince just looks at me goes Jesus Christ
Freddy walks away I'm like oh my god
dude blew me up in front of my boss
thanks
Jo that is amazing though to
continuously even at your age yeah still
get to learn more get to learn more the
good the bad the funny the ug you know I
don't you want you want a three
dimensional picture tell me about the
Ali story Okay so my dad to date is the
youngest person ever to host the Tonight
Show uh he did uh the the comedy bit on
Johnny Carson and Johnny brought him
over to the couch and two weeks later
asked him to host the [__] show for
him when he was with one of his ladies
yeah and uh my dad's guests were George
Foreman um Paul Williams um Paul
Williams who's my Uncle Paul still to
this day I he was the one who picked me
up from the airport in his black Ferrari
tester Roa the first time I ever came to
California still now this has been a
couple years the last time I saw him but
I remember seeing not maybe five six
years ago in Studio City thinking to
myself that's [__] Paul will he's
still such a boss dude he so freaking
cool same hair still right same hair can
still he's still wearing the same
glasses same glasses still was the voice
of the penguin in the awesome 90s Batman
anime
series the man so he has these guests on
and by the way can I just make a side
note 70s Hollywood
we need time machines Josh that is the
time to be here yeah do you know what I
mean and you know what else I like I
like I like who the 70 stars were yeah
man and the things they had to say I
just they were so people were pushing
social agendas in such an organic cool
funny [__] way and you were allowed
to speak yeah well there was no instant
audience feedback of hey that offended
me me too me too me too me too you know
it's just like I don't care if you're
offended [__] you you have no voice and
that's kind of what Hollywood was back
then like we are the voice of the
voiceless but you know what else they
were and I do miss this and it's one of
the reasons I'm glad Jack Nicholson
hasn't done 97 appearances on The
Tonight Show he's a [__] movie star I
like the separation he stayed magic you
know what say what you want about Leo I
like that he doesn't do a [__]
million people not dig Leonardo to car
they think he's aloof he's a movie star
killed a [__] bear are you [__]
me come I love Leonardo to the only
movie I didn't like was the not the
island what was that survival kind of
Lord of the Rings it was I think it was
called The Island the island whatever
but every other movie he's done I've
been like yo he kicked some ass in this
movie I I think he is like they just
don't like him cuz he's goodl looking
man and you know what else they don't
like him they don't like him cuz he's
he's skinny fat and he can [__] whoever
and he got jaelle bunin and didn't even
have to marry her like you know what I
mean like Tom Brady had to put a ring on
it Leo's like nah and most guys need to
die I don't play quarterback bro but
guess what I'm Leonardo C deal with it
most guys got to die and do situps to
get women he he rolls out of bed like a
pro poker player yeah full beard with a
big you could go three you I knew you
were going to do it as soon as we talked
about his I knew it but and he doesn't
care that's the same thing it's the same
thing with my theory on Johnny Depp and
Brad Pit when you're that good-looking
they're like let's see how ugly I can
get and still [__] whoever I want I so
hope that's how it works they're just
like I'm going to ugly it up and I'm
still going to just [__] whoever I want
how about that um I had such a complex
from being a dork as a kid I didn't try
to ugly it up too much although my
choices to look cool were somewhat
questionable I feel the same way like
I'm not confident enough to like the
'90s hair was just a Whole Decade did
you mull it no but I had like the side
spike in the 80s you did yeah and then I
had like the waack Sideburn spiky thing
in the '90s that's I went mullet I went
full that's worse yeah I did purple tips
in like different colors that sucks I
did um it's cool now the middle on my
back dude you went like Bon Joi Jersey
status big time with my [__] overall
only one girls with big time bangs had a
thing for you though overall with only
one strap no shirt underneath not you no
you're a comedian and that's a great
joke no I did I are you [__] me
overall one strap [__] yeah okay so my
bad choice that's your bad choice
although it's awesome my bad awesome
Choice was the Z cavari where you would
taper and roll it up and on the inside
of the pants was like cool yellow design
that was my horrible awesome Choice what
kind of shoes were you rocking uh I had
British Knights and I had
Converse it was New Mexico you had to
look harder you get the [__] kicked out
of you quick man really d i was part
Puerto Rican so it's was like I wasn't
Mexican enough for the Mexican dudes and
the white guys were like what's up
[__] and so you would fight but it's
just me and black dudes getting each
other's back that was it man did you
fight a lot growing up yeah but my
Godfather's Bob Wall man so it's like oh
that was the Ali store oh yeah yeah um
so my Godfather's a dude who literally
trained Bruce Lee when Bruce came to
America and Bruce trained him as well
but what kind of martial art would you
say Bruce Lee did he would call it
Western boxing it's technically defined
as jet kundo which is like a modified
version of Kungfu which which is why he
called it Western boxing which is
basically like strike the closest part
of your opponent with the closest part
of you so is there anything now that
he's close to that like any I mean I
think he brought a lot of Western boxing
into the Kung Fu he established a jab
that before a western just a jab where
you Shuffle the feed forward and Jab and
that wasn't something Kung Fu Tau a lot
no Kung Fu was a more squared stance and
he took a more I don't want to like make
Chinese people M but he took a more
Japanese karate stance as opposed to
being squared up so he turned his body
which seems to be smarter for fighting
yeah you're a smaller Target right like
that's why Floyd Mayweather never gets
hit he turns sideways there's less of
him to hit I've always
I've always said like I know people get
on Floyd Mayweather but if I was a boxer
I would try not to get hit too yeah I me
my issues with Floyd are more stop
hitting chicks start hitting women stop
being an [__] and knock out guys not
women once you do that ring yeah don't
get hit get i' like to see you try to
hit him too more but his hands have been
shattered for years is that true oh he
had to get those ladoc cane injections
you have broken hands his hands have
been shattered for years yeah so he's
beating people on picking his
spots which he can masterfully well I
don't know if he can do it anymore let's
see if he comes out of retirement I
don't I I think the only way he comes
out is if he comes out he fights
somebody his age he's almost my age and
I believe me I'm my brain sees a lot of
stuff that these young guys I'll box
with Wayne McCulla um he was a
three-time world champion boxer I
trained with Tony Ferguson he's a UFC
fighter on an eight fight win streak and
I'll see things that my brain's like
there it is move to the left go for the
liver and my legs are like man [__] you
[__] you br like like we went hiking
this morning bro are you crazy and I
just get smashed on we got up at eight
to make breakfast for the kids you D I'm
not stepping to my left [__]
watch 14 consecutive episodes of Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles I love Seth Green
but I'm done did you how many times have
you seen Frozen a lot a lot I can do the
movies the Disney movies a little bit
more cuz I was raised on like The Jungle
Book and [__] like that and I can always
say okay we watch Frozen but now we got
to watch an old school one
and do you do that yeah like we w we
read the Harry Potter books before she
gets to watch the movies so it's always
like one for one she has to have balance
you know what my balance with my with my
kids has always been mine is more with
toys every to every toy that you get one
leaves your room you get you get a new
toy we're donating one I like that a lot
so when holidays come you want a grip of
[__] prepare to get rid of a grip of
[__] we do like a year thing where it's
like hey find all the stuff you don't
play with anymore let's put it in a bag
and then we'll donate that's what we do
yeah for me it's like important for them
to
see it's not just you're not master
baits from the toy like toy dogs that
actually piss on your friends yeah and
you also like it's important like when
especially cuz Jakey Jacob got my two
oldest kids saw my ex getting your
stomach pumped they saw a bunch of [__]
and so they and they lived in some we
lived in some pretty I don't know we one
bedroom three kids $1,000 a month I
don't know if that's consider considered
poverty but it's not great it's not fun
it's not especially here in Hollywood I
could probably do that some places
around the country and be like oh you're
okay but in Hollywood yeah in Montana
you can pull that off probably so
probably so can't really pursue your
career in
Montana no comedy clubs aren that big
there I did a show a one nighter in
Montana once in Helena I think it was B
only City I know I think it was Bowman
it was a one nighter and I I forget it's
either Boseman or Billings or but it's
one of the bees you know every city in
Montana I was just joking I R st out
what the [__] when you do a [__] ton of
one nighters is is you're when you're
[__] cutting your teeth you really
but one of the B cities there was a lot
of uh we don't say midgets anymore right
what do we say little people there were
lot there was a lot of little people in
that community and so they were there
was like a whole table of them up front
and it's not a big deal but it's
probably a heads up for a comedian
though it's a heads up it's heads up you
should be given a Holy Grail you're like
and you sat up front it's just like you
know my wife once she was like Hey
someone's coming over to fix the
computer and I go okay and someone she
didn't I opened the door and it was a
little person yeah now look if it
catches you off guard yeah you're going
to make a weird face so I told her I
said I made a weird face and she goes
why I go why don't you [__] tell me
just give me a heads up and she goes I
didn't want to seem Prejudice I'm go
that's not prejudiced that's just saying
hey he's coming over you're like I'm the
one that's Prejudice help me out yeah I
hate I shouldn't admit to this but you
did I had the exact same thing we were
we were walking in New York through
Madison Square Park by The Shake Shack
there yeah and uh to get a burger and I
turned and there was a little person
like right up on me and it kind of
caught me off guard and they have that
short little like twot fence and I kind
of did a ho and hopped over it you and
Sarah goes Sarah goes what the what the
hell was that Freddy cuz the guy was
kind of like hot and I get it like and
instead of like owning up to it and
being like yeah I was messed up like go
why [__] snuck up on me Sarah freak me
out
cuz I didn't want to like admit like yo
I need to grow as a person but yes I've
grown since then well when you say grow
as a person is that a
dig believe you said that right after I
wish you'd talk about Knuckles and belly
right now tell me the Muhammad Ali story
okay by the way I have a terrible habit
of jumping off of topics I don't care
don't I do too um I have kids so we're
good man they do the same thing I'm like
what what what um so my dad did this
incredible impression of Ali beating
George in zier on The Tonight Show when
he hosted it and George did the bit with
him and my dad had this amazing Aldi
impression and he could even like you
know pretend to move like him and George
let him knock him out right and then
sign the gloves is that on YouTube cuz I
I'm sure it is if not we can find it
through NBC um and he signed the gloves
to Freddy best pal and champ George
Foreman and I had still have those and
as a kid I used say sign them to me
because kids didn't know about my dad um
so anyway um they did this and Ali
really liked my dad's impression and
they became friends and my dad used to
go to his house a lot and they would
Spar and Ali would whip his ass and like
he's pulling his punches but when Ali's
pulling his punches it's still way
sicker than you yeah my dad will go home
with black eyes and bloody noses and he
got sick of getting the [__] kicked out
of him and he heard that Steve M guys
like Steve McQueen and James Garner all
these La tough guys were training with
this dude named Bob wall and so he
started training with Bob and my
godfather taught him the the Tommy
Hearns check hook
which is a pivot off your front foot and
you move away and you hit them with your
front hand in a hook which is more like
a winging motion if you're not into
boxing by the way what a punch Tommy
Hearn it's like the Floyd that's the
only knockout Floyd gets is the check
hook these days but Tommy Hearn I like
for a dude that skinny to have that
power bro him and like Alexis aruo who's
more obscure those two guys had torque
that that is what it is right you know
what I'm saying like that Tor there's
leverage and then there's Leverage
that dude has bre in his glove can hit
and by it's like a whip so by the time
that fist gets there it's
just done I love the slow-mo when you
see someone's entire when the skin on
their face gets displaced to the other
half of their face text you some photos
I have some original prints of Madison
Square Garden fights of like sugaray
Robinson smashing kid gallivan's face
and it's it's just all mush and looks
CGI and it's black and white I'll I'll
I'll text it to you would love to see it
so my dad meets with Bob and he says you
got to teach me how to fight and Bob
says why and he tells him why my
Godfather's like holy [__] it's m so
he's teaching my dad you know how to
fight and they trained for about three
four months um and even after um all the
way up to the point where he passed away
and my godfather became my my teacher so
I got to learn a lot about my dad from
him too later in life um and still to
this day he holds out his stories on me
where he just forgets because he got
punched a lot but uh so my dad goes to
Ali's house one day and Ali's peppering
him just PO with this Jab dad's trying
to slip the jab and my dad gets a check
hook and boom and Ali they're in the
living room they're not in the backyard
and Ali Falls onto the couch like oh and
falls on the couch gloves no gloves
they're boxing with gloves my dad runs
in the bathroom he had bloody notes he
runs in the bathroom comes out he wipes
the blood off Ali's face jumps in his 75
metallic blue stingray and hauls ass
home Ali calls the house telling my mom
I'mma kill that boy you tell I'm going
kill that boy next time I see him my dad
framed the towel with the blood on like
it's a war metal on crushed purple
velvet in a dark wood frame and then it
has like a little uh plaque thing on it
it says
June 7th
1975 Ali's blood my my mom has it I've
asked for it a million times when I'm
dead it's yours but my mom still has it
to this day man that is crazy yeah dude
did he ever spar with him again um yeah
they sparred a bunch of times they and
Ollie would always pepper you know Oli
got a couple of after he saw a punch one
time he was like that's not going to
happen I never heard a story of my dad
hitting him a second time no that's like
Ali wasn't impossible to hit so he was
just that good that is you know that's
crazy is and then you go back to Floyd
like when you're when you're so good
that you are stopping other
professionals from hitting you yeah
that's when you know and you're making
them look like guys like you and me yeah
yeah that's when you dude I took like I
love Victor Ortiz but Floyd made him
look like I'd never seen him look in my
life I was like damn bro are you as into
UFC as you are into boxing yeah my
godfather was the first investor um for
H and Gracie when Horan invented it so
tell me something smart for McGregor to
go back against Diaz because here's how
and I you tell me you know way more
about it than I do here's my impression
from watching that first fight McGregor
is a better a more skilled fighter but
what he looked like is he just looked
like he ran out of steam he looked like
he punched him as many times as he could
punch him and then he was like this
dude's bigger than me he's stronger than
me and I'm out of gas what it looked
like that's a part of it but I don't
think that's the main reason um so I I
mentioned earlier I trained with Wayne
Mulla and he's way into the Irish boxing
scene and what a lot of people didn't
know when Connor was coming up is he was
an Irish boxing champion dude he throws
hands so his footwork is going to be
second to none in the division Domino
Cruz's footwork is amazing okay but he
doesn't set on both feet a lot which is
why he's not generating as much power on
those knockout punches now he doesn't
need to cuz Dominic will hit you with
seven punches and that's what he's going
for it's a deliberate thing but it's
just to demonstrate the difference in
MMA footwork to boxing footwork Connor's
feet he's not flat footed he's still on
the balls but he sits down on his
punches and counters you or will simply
do that triple jab moving forward that
for some reason no one else in the UFC
will do and it's one of the most
effective boxing because most those guys
don't start out as boxers right and they
don't use take advantage of the jab
which is the best thing for any fight I
won't say he's the better fighter it's
not cuz he was smaller Nate got 11 days
to train Nate boxes with dudes like
Andre Ward I know he looks awkward yeah
but just cuz you look awkward doesn't
mean you don't know the sweet science he
can box so big time he the only when
Wayne and I were talking about the first
fight and I even said this on on ESPN
Los Angeles before their first fight and
I said this is from Wayne's mine not
mine he's a lot smarter than me he said
if Nate can take his punches you'll know
in the first minute and if he can and
the fight's over which is exactly what
happened which is exactly what happened
now what Connor lacks
is any legit Jiu-Jitsu ability and any
legit wrestling ability his Taekwondo
top shelf his boxing top shelf his
wrestling is garbage and when he got
hurt and tried to shoot a double that
was a double that like my six-year-old
shoots you know what I mean and I'm
telling her baby no that's wrong you
know what I mean so and and he he has to
acknowledge that like it's not it was
not a good shot you don't shoot with
your head straight down so does he have
a shot this this I don't know what the
plan B is like they show videos of him
training and it's his trainer punching
him in the stomach a million times I'm
like when did Nate do that the first
fight right he choked you the [__] out
bro you need to be working on hip
escapes wrestling and avoiding a take 20
lbs lighter there's a reason there's
weight class divisions right do you have
a shot I mean against Gracie didn't have
an issue with it in the original UFC's
and granted the fighters weren't where
they are now but there is that
philosophy that exist and a jiu-jitsu
fighter would debate you on that big
time but a jiu-jitsu fighter is not what
McGregor is no but that's what Nate is
Nate is Uber black belt if you're if
you're boxer if you're and you're and
you're basically don't shoot don't shoot
but also don't fight somebody who's 20
PBS heavier than you right yeah but I
mean I feel like the bo like the
jiu-jitsu's philosophy is every fight
goes to the ground and boxing doesn't
teach you how to fight on the ground the
boxer's philosophy is everyone has a
button and if I touch that button you're
going to sleep so that's the debate like
that's what makes Combat Sports [__]
awesome and that's what makes it the
best sport in the world is it's I say my
boxing is better than your wrestling and
you say [__] you and okay let's find out
and there's no there's no question at
the end of it who won like Max Kellerman
the boxing analysis has great by great
dude and he knows his [__] dude he has a
great comparison he does for sports he
says say you're standing in the middle
of the street at an intersection with no
cars because we'll be safe uh one corner
p is doing sweet dribbling with the ball
y on another Corner uh Steph Curry's
doing you know sweet sweet moves on a
third Corner the best uh golfer in the
world is hitting drives and on the
fourth Corner two dudes are fighting
where's the crowd like everybody's going
to watch two guys throw the [__] down
yeah it's why pro wrestling still exists
today cuz even if it's choreographed
people want to see Man versus Man Woman
versus woman denim versus spandex as
long as it's versus spandex on well I
missed the '90s I mean denim versus
spanic I missed the 90s that actually
sounds like a prince band like a band
that he tried to put together oh on his
label Brothers took away cold he was
like hey I got an idea for a band called
denim versus spam what was the name of
his other label that he just would put
girls that he was sleeping went through
what was the name of that label in
Minnesota I think it was called Princess
dick dude is that what it was I I took
KRA Mah for a little while that's legit
okay and I used to spar and this is when
I knew that it was n just size it's not
just size oh no Str it's do you know
what you're doing right so it was okay
we went showed up to sparring class and
it was three guys and three girls so the
guy running the class set it up with two
girls two guys and then me and I was
going to spar with this woman and I was
like hey man I don't um I don't know how
I feel about sparring with her and he
goes just put your gloves on right so I
say to her I'm sitting down next to to
her right and we're wrapping our hands
and I say to her hey just you know I'm
not going to hit you and she goes I know
now when she said I know it was I
thought she was acknowledging that I
didn't want to hit a girl what she was
saying was no I've seen you fight you're
not gonna [__] touch
me okay
so I throw a jab I miss her I throw a JB
I miss her cuz I'm just trying to in my
mind take it easy on her yeah you ever
have a front a leg kick to your thigh
yeah a Muay Thai leg kick I fought Muay
Thai for 12 years it takes the will to
fight away from the guy you're fighting
yeah because when by the way the leg
kick is the best street fight move there
is because it makes the guy that wanted
to look tough suddenly go because you
can't put the pressure down on your so
she hit me with three really good have
fun with that you don't know how to leg
check I didn't know how to leg
check so she had seen me Spar before
that's right I was sparring with people
way below her level so she had eyed me
out and been like oh he if I ever fight
him I can do this I'm hitting him with a
leg kick that's cold bled right so I
couldn't put my front foot down because
by the way did you put your arm down to
block one then she threw a hook and
knocked my mouthpiece out across the
room that's what we do too and then so
they blew the guy rang the bell and he
was like you can't fight her she beat
the [__] out of me the bruise on my leg
dude was a [__] real deal I remember
the Muay Thai days man so the guy who
was the referee by the way is vicious
it's it's rough man that leg Kick's no
joke and they build up that calcium yeah
we would get a stick and we would whack
our shins and then roll and the guy who
was the referee from the first Karate
Kid movie his name was Pat Johnson we
just called him Master Pat that's the
dude that taught me how to leg kick when
I was like five years old dude I got
spoiled around have you done one of
those to some a million of those like in
New Mexico when like gangs would try to
rank you in cuz it was a big time gang
problem in the in the in the 90s big
time cuz a lot of the 18 Street Crips
from La went there because it was easier
to get drugs across the the juad Border
than the Tijuana border um and so guys
will fight you hit a guy with a leg kick
with the sharp part of your shin and
they reconsider fighting you real I've
had literally guys I think I was maybe
15 16 at a putt putt as a miniature golf
place in Albuquerque and this guy was
big and hard and tough and I cracked him
with one leg kick and literally made him
say man [__] it and he split you can't
do anything it takes the will to fight
from someone who's not used to it now
it's a more common thing and now if you
fight somebody and you see him do that
you're like oh this fool might know
what's going on with a leg check with a
leg check yeah but if you get caught
with a good Shin coming down at that
right Ang the correct angle it almost
feels like it cuts through your muscle
that's what and then when they know they
hurt you they fake low and go high with
that kick and then it's sleep sleep time
here's what she did she was super nice
to me and she didn't kick me in the face
but she punched me in the face that's
good and when the M you got headgear on
right or Krab MCA is like we're tougher
we don't need head gear KRA M was
interesting because you know what I had
never been to a fighting place where the
guy was like Hey I go was that fair and
their rule is there's no such thing as a
fair fight a yeah street fight is you do
what you got to do yeah the guy that
taught me he was like listen I can't
teach it in class but you know the eye
gouge is very
effective like really like okay poke him
in the eye Ric Flair style [__] yeah
W how many fights you think you got into
before you left me New
Mexico uh that I was fighting a lot
really you did you but when you came out
here that stopped I've been in three
fights since 1994 but I Spore like three
or four times a week um you still love
it yeah man it's I teach my kids you
know I I'm down at glove Works come spar
with us like you know what I mean like
guys will most of the time we're pretty
chill I had a i you you don't say names
in the gym but some kid who was 19 years
old kind of called me out at the gym
and I was tired man I'm like man this
kid wants to go I looked at Wayne and
Wayne just looks at me go he just nodded
his head I was like yeah all right dude
come in I put it on this kid's body so
bad he literally just gave himself to me
against the ropes to where I literally
was it just boxing or everything just
boxing and I put it on his body so nice
that he was not going to fight back and
I tapped him on the shoulder to back off
cuz there was like 30 seconds left and
Wayne yells don't stop that's what he
wanted so I peppered him up a little
more and this uh this UFC fighter this
UFC fighter comes up to me like 5
minutes later he goes you know that
kid's still puking in the bathroom right
I was like oh you just made a
40-year-old feels so [__] good the
body shot can change somebody's decision
to fight too oh yeah that liver shot's
no joke no joke forget a liver shot just
when you get a body shot or even someone
hits your stomach you're not expecting
it oh yeah oh hard to look tough it
hurts when Wayne has mits on and he's
just like playing with me he'll just
touch me on and I'm like dude that
honestly hurt don't do it again listen
I'm paying for this session [__]
for real it's tender down there bro
tender I'm not a tough guy man I don't
like getting hit that's why I do you do
teach so you're teaching your kids yeah
man um I I try to do a lot of work not
just with my kids but um I've worked
with autistic kids UJiT well Jiu-Jitsu
is really good at getting you
comfortable with closeness like a CB
mcra do or like an amateur wrestling
would do which is something a lot of uh
kids with Asbergers and and and autism
with and I've I witnessed it with this
UFC fighter Brian Ortega who was the guy
who helped me get my blue belt back in
the day and now he's an undefeated UFC
fighter and I watched him work with this
non-communicative uh autistic kid and he
didn't know what to do it was Jiu-Jitsu
that did it um he got to be sort of the
tool to to to turn the bolt that made
everything click for this kid but the
kid couldn't speak to him and finally
Brian just pinned him down the way you
would pin someone down said do you want
me to get off off you and and I see this
little boy he's going and he goes you
want me off and he goes H and he goes
put your hand right here and he puts his
hand on his wrist he goes put your other
hand right here and the boy puts his
hand behind his elbow and he squeeze
hard and he squeezes hard he goes Now
hook my foot and he helps the boy hook
his foot he says now make a bridge make
a bridge I won't say the boy's name yeah
um and the kid makes the bridge and he
flips Brian over and I watch how old's
the boy uh he's a third grader so I old
Yar in the eight eight yeah um he flips
Brian over and Brian been working with
this kid for three months kid had never
spoke
and he yells as better than I do I did
it and I see this tough guy I'm not
going to say that cuz that happened in
the gym but he was very moved by what
this young boy not be by what this young
boy did and I was like yeah I got to do
that um so I started working a lot of
that and then I'm trying to start a
program for uh veterans and for kids um
CU I had a lot of family that served one
of my best friends I do Jiu-Jitsu with
served one of my other best friends is
active in the Marine Corps and they all
do Jiu-Jitsu and I want to bring that to
the veteran Center over on the west side
instead of a hedge maze how do you feel
like that helps I think again the the
comfort with closeness is good I'm also
want to bring Wayne and some of these
old school martial arts guys because
Bruce Lee said at best martial arts is
the physical expression of what we love
and hate most about ourselves and his
students he
found came to him because they had [__]
going on that they could not verbally
communicate because there were walls
there and martial arts brought all those
feelings out and I'm a big I know that
sounds like Eastern hookie dookie sorry
I was raised by Bob Wall so that's what
I believe and I've seen it work so we're
big fan of hookie dookie here hookie
doie is good
man big fan of the hookie doie big fan
of the hook I've seen your High watchs
um love the hook so you know being
raised on that and and like I also this
sounds way on the opposite end of the
spectrum but I do something called
twitch where you play video games so
people can watch you play and see what
you're playing and they can communicate
and speak with you um whether they're
just fans watching or if other people
online want to play the game you're
playing you can communicate with them
and I I speak with a lot of veterans
oddly enough on there who use video
games as a tool and have already like
communicated directly with them like
come down to La man come roll some
Jiu-Jitsu with me come see how feels and
they've all talken spoken to me about
pts talking spoken to me about PTSD and
things like that and how they felt that
could be cool so I'm trying to bring
those guys down too and all the guys I
roll with are like dude come roll for
free like you know they're just they're
it's a
good not only skill to have but again
like Bruce Lee said it really does help
with confidence with fear with with
discipline with all those things man so
I'm a huge proponent and that's my so
boox I will tell you this and by the way
you're a complex dude you're a complex
dude man like you you youve you've feel
pretty simple actually yeah you because
of all the different things that you've
experienced in your life I definitely
got to be raised it seems like you came
out the other side with like this is
what's important to me this is what's
important to me and this is what's
important to me and the rest of that
[__] I don't not going to worry about
anymore it's funny I I did an interview
with Howard Stern like right in like
what year was I cool like 97 98 it's
cool still right now all right we're
rocking the 90s still so and he was
talking to me about how he said what
would you be doing if you acting I was
like man I just you know try to open a
restaurant play video games be married
with my wife he's like man you and Sarah
ain't going to be together in seven
years I'll bet you and we bet a million
dollars he still hasn't pay me by the
way we bet a million dollars on the air
that uh Sarah and I would still be
together and I look at my life now we've
been together 15 years I wrote a
cookbook
um I had this are you happier now yeah
like I I I cooked for Mario battal and
Michael Simon on their show and in the
commercial break um they both came and
spoke to me about some really cool stuff
that would be like if you wanted to play
football and Vince Lombardi gave you a
pep talk and you just be like what the
[__] I think I can I think I can do this
so those guys at the break showed me a
lot of love and and I've been talking to
them about a few different ideas now and
they've been really good to me and and
passionate with with my ideas and so
I've known who I wanted to be for a long
time I I chose to act to sort of right y
or wrongfully however you feel about my
grandpa uh I moved here in '94 and I I
stopped when our I pretty much stopped
when our daughter was born I mean I
shouldn't say this cuz I don't feel
great about it but they pay a lot of
money in Hollywood so I did a few jobs
where I was just like man I can't say no
you know what I mean but and I my I
won't say the movies cuz I love those
directors and writers and I don't want
to like dump on anyone but I did a few
others after I was done with one foot
out the door and then once I could step
away clean I stepped away clean so I
could be be a full-time dad I have
responsibilities to to certain kids like
I said um and I don't break promises to
kids I'll break a promise to a grown-up
that don't mean [__] to me but a kid you
can't do that man because that that
scars them and sour them uh for life at
least it did to the people who who
couldn't keep them with me so uh so that
stuff became really important and I
threw my life into that and a surfboard
and and things got better quick now
listen this is the first time you and I
have ever met face to face yeah but what
strikes me about you is that you do seem
extraordinarily present
and uh the word I'm going to use the
word calm like most I will tell you I
feel yeah that I agree with for sure
there are a lot of people in this town
and I'm sure you know a bunch of them a
lot of them are my friends and they're
they're constantly fidgety there's no
they heart peace yeah but you seem very
at peace and calm dude with how the path
clearly was a little bumpy getting you
here but oh yeah you don't if you work
everything out by the time you're 20 God
love you but you got to be lying to
yourself somewhere on that road you know
it took me a long time but I when did
you realize you did not love
acting um you know I did a movie with
Parker posie that made me love it um and
so for a good five years why what was
that experience
she's Parker posy vomits energy wherever
she goes and if it hits you
you're infected like you just can't you
just can't help it like she has this I
was maybe 19 when we worked together it
was a movie it was called The House of
Yes uh Mark Waters uh adapted it from
the play and directed it he did Mean
Girls and and other stuff as well and uh
I was in love with her I wanted her to
be my girlfriend my sister my mom like
my acting coach my everything like
combination yeah like I wanted her to be
every part of my life and I feel like
most people when they meet her feel the
same way cuz when I talked I've talked
to like Jimmy Fallon a few times we be
became friends on uh SNL when I host
that a long time ago and right when they
first started dating I was like man I
just had this weird he goes dud I feel
the same way you know what I mean it was
just like it's just she has this aura
about her you know and that made me fall
in love with it and unfortunately that
was my first movie and then uh you know
as I got older and and I I saw more of
that it was like my uncle always told me
and I told you he's the smartest guy I
know and he was my dad D manager he
always would say Freddy it's Show
Business and business is the bigger word
yes and when that kind of I was old
enough and experienced enough to
understand that I said yeah I need to
pursue stuff I love and that was sort of
when the plan started and it took me
probably three years to uh to get on
board with the plan that that I was
trying to get on but once I did I didn't
I didn't look back and I felt really you
know and I've been calm for a while but
once I had kids everything that changes
everything yeah then all of a sudden
all my priorities in my top 10 were like
you know I I that's what happened to me
people would like I would uh with Mo
Jacob I used to have to because I was
single at the time I used to have
audition with him in in asleep in a baby
little beorn dude I brought my little
man on a on a voice recording thing and
he I was like you got to stay quiet and
when I finished he goes I
quiet so at two cuz I I would do my
lines in front of him at two he could
sit next to the casting director and
know when to laugh so I would do the I
would hit the joke and he'd be
like yeah that's money we walk out I'd
be like you killed it that's next level
right there nailed it nailed it I will
tell you something also I'm surprised I
haven't seen like single father actors
pulling that move oh it's such a like if
you you shouldn't have said that on it
you need to mute this part of the show
that's a gangster move right there well
now it's not his gangster he's like a
grown person no I'm saying for other
actors out there tell people all the
time bring your kid you know what I used
to do cuz my cousin is like and it'll
distract your opponents in there cuz
remember the union is not a family what
can I tell you something you know what I
did used to do my cousin is a guy named
Scott wolf right oh yeah okay and so
during party five at one time was the
biggest show yeah for like five years
bro not at one time it was a huge show
there was one time there was this
audition I really wanted I go hey Scotty
will you come with me and he's like why
I'm like just cuz when you walk into the
room ahead of me people are going to be
like what the [__] is guy throws him off
their
game such a Boston move dude that's such
a Boston dick move oh my God it's money
I wish I would have thought of it so I
had him go in ahead of me like a couple
minutes and you could see people get in
there and they would like he would he
signed in he signed you had him sign
signed in so they would come up just to
make sure to see if it was see they come
down and check the list and be like
[__] Scott that's like
mob by the way you guys are dicks I
didn't book one of them it's still a
great move bro I I didn't one and I will
tell you something and I I don't know if
I've if anyone's ever mentioned you this
before my brothers and I all I have
three older brothers we all will say
unequivocably that the first Scooby-Doo
is the most underrated comedy of all
time really dude and now maybe because
my my expectations were
low there we go now the truth goes out
when we sat in the theater and we were
yeah I walked out of the theater with my
three brothers and I'm like that was
[__] hilarious you know the writer um
James gun who's now Guardians of the
Galaxy famous his original draft you
guys would have gone bananas for um it
was a movie for Stoners dude it was
supposed to be and then we got a new
draft when we landed in Australia ah and
uh the Warner conveniently waited until
we landed youil Australia yeah the first
one um I'll be honest
I haven't seen the
movie I read the script I Know How It
Ends I've only seen three jobs that I've
ever done like it just I I have to tell
you PR make me awkward I completely get
it I've been on I was probably on over
250 episodes of Chelsea how many did you
watch I've seen one my wife told me to
say hi cuz we used to always crack the
hell up I mean first of all whoever
chose that Squad that you guys ran with
her she did her okay
I hope she hears this you're [__]
awesome and the level of talent
comedians that you brought up this isn't
for you this is for her yeah was I put
the mic down so awesome like it she made
you guys the stars of the damn show and
it was up to you to sink or swim like a
Marvel Superhero not a DC Superhero
where you're protected it was deep into
the pool they don't like him off with
his head and when you guys would shine
man like my wife and I would sit and
crack the hell up and it made us follow
a lot of you guys not on social media
cuz I didn't have it back then but when
you guys would perform like we would
want to know about it and we would want
to see it and I'm so stoked to hear you
say it was her here's what she did there
were shows and this is the best part
about her and I know people have their
own opinion about her and whatever
whatever I think she's funny as hell
she's funny as [__] do you need another
water buddy I'm cool right now all right
let me know um here's the best thing
about her her ego
say what you want but most people in her
position would make sure that she had
the best joke and always ended with the
best joke a lot of insecure people would
do that yes she's not insecure she's not
a beta she's not Sally Field she's not
you like me you really like me like
Sally Field wasn't sick until she won an
Academy Award but so many of the people
in Hollywood are beta personality
meaning they're so susceptible to comp
compliments and criticism she's an alpha
person she's Kobe Bryant Kobe you suck
whatever Kobe you're great whatever
already knows how she feels about the
bit long before you do she there was one
show where she would read the topic and
I remember specifically I think it was
me uh a guy named it was me Joe Koy it
might have been me Joe Koy and Ben Glee
it was a good little group great Squad
yeah and we ran with the show and after
the show I remember saying to her you
didn't say anything she goes you guys
were funny I didn't have to say anything
that's money dude but that's what it's
about man that's it she didn't care who
was shining is the show Good
there aren't too many people who would
do that you let the jokes dictate where
the show yeah man funny wins and that's
how she always was and by the way like I
and yall had to fight it out like oh
dude cuz y'all were sharp man you guys
were sharp much like the Marvel
superhero if you said something on there
that wasn't funny she was going to tell
you yeah you're done she made Bobby Lee
sit under the table his first joke was
so bad right his first joke was so bad
she goes Bobby you're going to need to
sit under the table for the rest of the
show that's all right my dad had a
couple B and she was like he was like no
not really and she goes Bobby get under
the table and he delivered cuz he still
had that's a better bit than the
punchline he
deliver that's a Vince McMahon move
right there him under the table but I
will tell you I learned more from her
and from I had a chance to talk to stern
but I her basically message was and this
was so it it helped my comedy more than
she'll ever know her message was hey
[__] everybody else does it make you
laugh and if it makes you laugh if you
build it they will come yeah do the
jokes pretend it's you and your brothers
high in a living room tell those jokes
yeah those jokes are s are true to you
she's V she's to you what Vince McMahon
was to me like did he give you that he
would try to give everyone that but his
demographic was so far removed from the
talents that they didn't always
understand the message but he was trying
to say what Chelsea would say to you
guys and so my job literally became at
one point a translator and he ran what
he called a promo class which was like
an acting class wait what did you do at
WWE okay so the first time I was there I
was a writer and producer which
basically means you have to do and why
how did you get were you always a
wrestling fan since I was a kid and I
always like the bad guys cuz we who was
your favorite Coco beware no he was a
good guy I didn't I did like jyd though
um Junkyard Dog junkyard dog was dope
but I always like the bad guys cuz the
good guys only one on the paper
and because Vince's philosophy was
always we'll see the bad guy you know
[__] him over [__] him over and if you
want to see your guy win you got to pay
um which worked smart became a
billionaire um so I always like the guys
that won every week because we were
broke and I couldn't afford the damn
pay-per-views so my favorite guys were
Andre the Giant and Ric Flair and I
hated Hogan and I hated the good guys
Andre the Giant wasn't always a bad guy
not always he became a baby face that's
their term for a good guy um eventually
but during the Hogan days he was the bad
guy he was the heel that's their name so
I always had love for it I went to a
show and one of the people who worked
there who kind of organized me getting
there it was a WrestleMania um she heard
me McCully culin Snoop Dogg and The Miz
having a conversation about wrestling
what we liked and what we didn't right
and she liked what I had to say um Snoop
was pretty high and uh and uh I'm so
surprised you m mcgall was
muli and uh
I love you bro enjoy
France
um I miss him come back I enjoy France
is one of my best my favorite throw
lines that's ever been on this podcast
by the
way almost stepped in it yeah that's
enjoy FR so she spoke to me about some
of my ideas and opinion said you know
would you ever consider and I had just
kind of stepped out of acting she said
would you ever consider you know working
for the WWE I said what are you talking
about and uh she she goes just have a
conversation with Stephanie and and see
what happens that's Vince's daughter
Stephanie McMahon and I had an apartment
in New York that uh was in the same
building as Shane McMan and I knew Shane
a little bit his son and so I went up
there and we just talked philosophy and
she said would you want to work here and
I was staying in my place in New York at
the time and their home base was
Stanford Connecticut I took a 30 minute
train to get there and uh I was like
well what do you what do you want me to
do and she was like well you would write
and you would direct and you would kind
of help my dad out he's you know he
tries to do like an acting class for him
but maybe you could you could help I was
like yeah okay me let me see yeah and so
I went and I watched the promo class and
you know he told these first two dudes I
don't want to say their names but he
made him come up and he says all right
your dogs now make me want to watch you
fight and it's dead quiet and both guys
are young in their 20s and neither one
is a thespian so they're both
like I'm [__] do like they don't know
what to do and so the first guy God
bless him man he had the balls to go
first but he instead of talking he He
barked oh like a dog yeah like a real
dog and Vince and Vince gets up and he
goes what the [__] not a [__] dog
and he just goes off and the other guy
when Vince finishes his monologue
literally says I think I'm having an out
to Body Experience he this Irish guy and
so when it was over he comes up to me
he's like so what do you think of that
and I'm like well you're using words
like razzled Dazzle and they don't know
what that means and I get the Vaudeville
thing wrestling is Vaudeville it's got a
song Break a comedy bit a magic like
that's what it is and he's like yes
that's what it is I go right but you
didn't say that like you you said Raz
Dazz and told him to be a [__] dog
and I said look I know what you want you
want them to be able to say [__] it and
not worry about failing on live TV
because if you're afraid you're going to
fail you will every time if you just say
oh I fell on my face and the next day I
woke up and everything was okay you're
going to succeed at just about every
[__] thing you try and that's what he
wanted and so and this they failed in
front of all their peers all the
decision makers on their on their
careers like everyone I said hey man
they're sensitive the tough love thing
not working let me handle this no
cameras no agents the agents are like
the the Bookers of the matches and on
the road are the most important wheel in
the machine wait so in different cities
there are different Bookers no they
travel all together as one massive
company one massive tour how many people
you think probably over 200 people
easily when a whole crew when that comes
into a city 200 people show up easy easy
200 that's not counting behind the
scenes people or it is that's with
behind the scenes and the the roster is
almost 80 deep Bro like they don't
travel everywhere every week some guy
might get hurt a match might change last
minute hey we're going to give the young
kid a push get his ass in there it is
fly by the seat of your pants live TV
and I would be trying to Wrangle these
kids and literally I would do read
sometimes cuz we would only have like 10
minutes I'm like do it how I do it Bo
boom boom boom and he's like okay start
over start over and we would do it again
and then they go out and they would sink
or swim but when they would swim man I
was able to do some really fun stuff
there that they hadn't done before when
with I know the matches are are clearly
the endings are planned yes how much is
it chore how much is it an actual dance
how much is it choreographed I'm sure
there are specific moves that are
choreographed yes but every single dance
and punch and and jump and kick can't be
choreographed can it every match is
different there's always going to be a
few spots that they call that the
wrestlers have a few combinations right
I throw you off the ropes I knock you
down I run I jump over you you get up
you jump over the big moves there's some
combinations that are all known but they
really let the talent if they're able
and capable to dictate the terms and the
story they want to tell hey man yeah hey
man I want to work on your leg in this
match okay cool you work the leg they do
it before they say beforehand yeah and
then they go in there and they bust out
freestyle but they're they're on the
road 300 days a year working all these
like techniques and dances and doing all
so a lot of it is ad libed on the Fly
based on how the crowd is reacting and
sometimes like I'd be sitting backstage
in the gorilla position and we'd give
him the gorilla position Gorilla Monsoon
was like he had the best seat in the
house he was the old school announcer by
the way the gorilla position has a
completely different meaning in my house
no this was like Gorilla Monsoon was the
voice of whenever I tell my wife go get
in the gorilla position it's a whole
different it's a different but go ahead
I go gorilla knuckle deep um and that's
a big knuckle but so sometimes you'll
get more time in a match and and you'll
convince to the referee hey we're
pushing the commercial Monday Night
Football went to commercial so we're
going to stay live give the guys another
three minutes and then the guys or the
girls nowadays sometimes get commercial
breaks and still time on the matches cuz
their matches started rating higher than
some of the guys
and so now you're really starting to see
these people quite literally put Blood
Sweat and Tears on a canvas but it
happens on the to be able to do that on
the a lot of it on the Fly you got to be
dope yeah because you they must be
talking to each other during the match
you have yeah oh yeah there's
communication like if somebody like has
someone they're choking them from behind
their mouth right next to their ear so
they're like okay listen for the crowd
all right here they come okay now fight
your way up fight your way up fight your
way up okay now I'm going to smash you
down again
all right now wait wait you got right so
there's stuff like that or like the old
school veteran when they're teaching the
kid when he pins him he'll be like you
know get up and and act like you won and
it'll be one two and he'll just kick out
at three and the young kid will get up
and be like yeah and then the old crafty
veteran gets up and then gets the win
and that'll be an on thefly kind of
thing so long as the veteran was going
to win the whole time so there was like
there was an old school guy named Larry
zabis who famous for that kind of just
allowing the match to take take shape
organically as opposed to anything other
than the Finish but doesn't that lead
itself and I'm all I got to tell you
dude what here's why I'm so impressed by
these people mhm they're massive people
doing gymnastics in a tiny little ring
yeah with another massive person also
doing gymnastics and throwing hands and
feet that hurt that hurt if you don't do
it correctly and if you do right yes I
totally get that like but like that's
part of the dance right so you
understand putting people's careers in
your hands multiple times per match yeah
how do I not see more or read about more
injuries how is that possible you know a
lot of these I'm sure you'll hear more
about it on the Indie scene but on the
major tours you're dealing with
professionals who know how to fall know
how to protect and know how to keep
their body where they need to keep it
how can they not much like a football
player wake up wait look if you're three
I mean they have a lot of the same
issues football players cuz I'm 170 lb I
fell on the front yard the other day I
was sore for 3 days I don't know the
last time I hit the ground I was like I
haven't hit the ground in a long time
bro I've done nothing and just woken up
been like my hammies are just shredded
right now what happened have you started
making old man noises yet oh yeah yeah I
walk in rooms and be like the [__] am I
when you reach for something you're like
oh yeah oh I've already been like
Charlotte can you get the
remote done it already but these guys
don't get enough for the athletes they
are do they no but I think you know on a
whole if it's something that you don't
understand or you don't like The Human
Condition is to shat upon it so it is
what it is but it's art like they're not
wrong it's you can't be wrong it's just
like I don't think Picasso is the
greatest painter ever I don't I think I
think amadel modani was way cooler and
I'm right and if you like Picasa more
you're right so it doesn't bug me when
people dump on it I thought it was funny
when Connor said said he would kill
everyone on the roster yeah um big dudes
that ain't true there's some big dud and
there's some legit legit fighters in
there oh yeah there's who the legit guys
I
mean there's a dude named MVP that if
Connor rumbled with would get his head
ripped off who do you think is the
biggest all right you know okay who is
the biggest I had an argument is not the
right word but conversation the biggest
wrestling star of all time
is it Hulk Hogan or is it the rock or
some the guy who I was talking to was I
guess John Cena he's bigger than any of
them I've ever been the ratings wouldn't
agree with that are those the three
biggest those would be the three biggest
I would say that with stone cold in
there as a top five and Andre because he
was such a global legend legend
everywhere he went but has anyone done
numbers like the rock or Hulk Hogan and
ratings wise would not say that Cena was
more popular than the rock because the
ratings are you know a third of what
they were when The Rock was wrestling
now there's a lot more channels now and
it's a different beast but John Cena
held that company on his back during a
PG era that no one wants to admit to but
it was a necessary thing when you're a
publicly traded company right and he did
it willingly wanting knowing that he
would get crapped on knowing that people
cutting promos on him would be like your
matches are on early cuz all your fans
are asleep by the time the show's over
Triple H cut that on him in a promo and
it's like he married the boss's daughter
so you can't even say [__] back you're
just like oh I got to take that I was
like when that rapper I think it was
Cannabis tried to talk about LL Cool J
and he's like 90% of your fans are all
women and LL return with like 90% of
your fans don't exist like he got to
have a comeback John Cena didn't get to
have one so to take that much abuse and
people would crap on him all the time
and they would hold up these signs at
every match they have C no wins we riot
but I never saw those [__] Riot once
I shouldn't even call them [__]
[__] are strong they push out babies
yeah whatever you guys were you're weak
and you never rioted once tell me what
twitch is okay I think I don't I don't
think now I did not get caught with the
Video Game Craze I'll get you're lucky
man I will you know I'll play my son I I
see a little action over there my son
loves he loves it your son knows about I
don't mind playing a little uh whatever
mortal not mortal combat whatever the
fighting game and I just press all the
buttons all Mortal Kombat is a great
game my son hates playing you're what's
called a button Masher that's what he
said to me yes he goes I can't [__]
play with you I'm like why not he goes
you just Mash all the time so if you
beat him like someone said that to me
once during a twitch stream and all I
came back with he's like he goes this is
what it's like playing with you and he
just tapped all his buttons and you
could hear I go yeah that's Morse code
for I Just Whipped your
ass and he didn't say [__] after that
but you know what I do like about it
because I not a big video game guy but I
do love talking [__] yeah it's a great
venue for that is it a great venue for
it and I love like I love talk like I
made a black dude in New York on a
basketball court leave and not come back
like I will talk cuz I'll know real
quick about your family about your dad's
situation about your mom's situation
dude it's it can't be I can go
in do you have brothers and sisters no
see that's surprising to me cuz I now I
have three older brothers but most
single like only children that I know
aren't great at talking [__] because
because it wasn't in their house all the
time see my wife would sum this up and
my and this is thanks to my godfather
basically cuz when people talk trash he
always goes you don't give a [__] about
like what anyone says I'm like no I
don't like even if they go hey you're
awesome I'm like yeah cool that's cool I
don't I don't care so no matter what you
say to me like I just think okay if he's
saying that he thinks that that'll hurt
me because he knows it'll hurt him so I
just go deep in on the psychiatric tip
on everything people say and most of the
time you'll find out out you're right oh
yeah and that just smashes guys but the
fun ones are like when you're playing
kids and they're like damn my name's
cheeks junor uh CHS J it was Chico Jr
but I got tired of hearing all the
racist [__] every open Lobby I'd go
in so I changed it to cheeks and uh you
know when you get like 12-year-old kids
you get real mad at you and I'm like hey
man I'm talking to your mom right now
about getting rid of your Xbox Live
account cuz you just ain't good enough
and these kids will be like 12 years old
and ruin their [__] days they'll send
me messages in game which means you had
to stop playing video games open another
window and without a keyboard with a
joystick and button select every letter
that you wanted to write to me I've
affected your day and it's the ultimate
troll tell you how much you like how
much I enjoy that you're talking [__] to
12-year-olds makes me laugh my son said
the same thing that's how the old 80s
movies were the grown-ups were mean to
the kids man Richard Pryor was mean as
hell he was Jack Brown and he whooped a
kid he whooped him I [__] love that
yeah the the talking [__] is an art
because I'm with you if your last name
isn't wolf you can't hurt my feelings I
tell people yeah if I don't have if you
haven't earned my respect it's really
tough for the message to get through
I'll say yeah right on you know what I
mean I'll be find is a good one
especially for dudes online who troll
you know what gets them mad than
anything they'll say something I always
get we [__] deal there this I can
tell you what the three insults for me
are dless comedian okay mhm you wouldn't
be anything without Chelsea which is
possible sure I wouldn't be anything
without my dad yeah I mean like I I'm
okay still cool yeah yeah and I haven't
seen you in any
movies I and my answer to all every guy
and this is what gets him
so these the I call them little anytime
you call one of those guys little fella
I'm like don't worry about it little
fell little fella pipsqueak little fella
hey little buddy or little buddy oh it
drives them [__] crazy oh that's your
best comeback as a comic oh you seem mad
little guy dude the the ones I get will
be like guys will be like will I jerk
off to your wife and I'm like me too
like
bro your your your knock on me is that
you jerk off to women you can't get but
I can like how am I I'm laughing at you
dog like what was that you're knock to
me is that my wife's good-looking and
likes me and would never like you all
right bro good luck to you good insult
like I don't
understand how those things hurt but you
know I guess it does a lot of but but
but it goes back to like beta and Alpha
oh definitely definitely definitely was
there a point in time in your life where
it would have bothered you as a teenager
maybe
but but then you were I was exposed I
was exposed to my Godfather's way of
life real early on and when I listened
to what he said things worked out for me
and when I didn't they didn't and I
would go to him when I had a hard time
talking to my mom about things cuz I was
prepubescent and wanted like a man to
and he was the toughest guy I knew yeah
um and I would tell him and he'd say
well did you do this this and this and
I'd say no and he go there you go and it
was always a real simple thing like it
hurts when I do this don't do that you
know what I mean and it just and you
hear that a million times eventually you
go oh yeah a car is built to get you
from point A to B and anything it does
for you outside that is making up for
character you think you lack you think I
made that up no I've heard that a,1
times and so I can just say it by rot
like and so I drive a [__] Toyota
4Runner from 2011 that's got 96,000 mil
on it because it runs like a g you know
what I mean and I've never bought like
fancy cars I like old cars you know I
mean I get some old cars but I've never
cared about all that crap and a lot of
that is because of him all right I'm
going to ask you a question that I just
thought of and because look obviously a
male a male role model growing up for a
boy is super important oh yeah okay do
you think somewhere because I do have a
couple parenting questions for you and I
ask everybody who's a parent but do you
think somewhere in you you were like
a i for a while grew up without a father
my kids are not I'm stopping acting I'm
going to be home that was yeah motive
one yeah is was that motive one motive
one where you were like this is I know
how it was for me that's not how it's
going to be for them there's no way in
hell that I'm going to leave my children
to go to London for 6 months to like do
a Star Wars Kanan movie like I just I
would love to like people always are you
going to do a a real version of the
cartoon you do I'm like they'll find
someone younger like it's just not I
love Star Wars like I've always said
there's like there's one role that I
would come out of retirement for and it
would be if they ever did a Vince biopic
I would want to play a Young Vince
McMahon when he United all the wrestling
territories and took over like in the
ancient Chinese Empire when he United
the Clans and formed one currency like
Vince studies this old [__] like that's
why he makes hyper intelligent yeah yes
and with no college degree yes and
people think he's old and crazy he's
crazy like a fox I spent two years with
the man like on his jet with him side by
side I was on the road every single live
show oh my God man just about business
and general he would make me laugh he
would make me go oh what the hell are
you talking about and he made me smarter
you know what I mean all those things
but look my godfather always told me
take advice from people more successful
than you don't take advice from your
friends cuz they're [__] losers and
they're living month-to month and
they're drunk and their girlfriends
cheat on them and they cheat on their
girlfriends so why would you listen to
what your friends say and you're like
well cuz they're my friends but when you
say like that it sounds horrible yeah
and so I would talk to people who are
always more successful than me and
instead of asking their favorite color I
ask them how they got successful I gotta
tell you when I I had a chance to
obviously I've used Chelsea a lot I had
I had a chance to talk to stern for
about 10 minutes and it was this same
thing like I'm not wasting my time
asking you your likes and like dislikes
for movies I'm saying how did you get
where you were so you that was the
decision con decision for you yeah you
can't you can't be a passive student you
have to be an active student if you're
not and it's so easy with the internet
and all these things cuz information
comes to us and we feel like it comes at
a very accelerated rate you should see
how fast it comes to you if you go seek
it out you know what I mean and so
that's how I was raised laziness was not
allowed balance was important my
godfather would teach me with Jean leel
the guy who taught Ronda Rousey's mom
Judo was the first guy to ever choke me
out I got to train Judo with him for an
hour and then I'd have to go Garden for
an hour because that's what balance was
to my godfather Karate Kid [__] dude
when you're a kid that sucks balls man
liter the worst it is and this was like
before that damn movie even came out and
so it sucked but when you get older
you're like wow I'm doing that to my
kids okay then that's my question right
because I ask everybody who's a parent
because it's always fascinating to me
okay what did you okay two two things
one what what do you hope that your kids
do get from you and what do you hope
they don't that's first question I'm
already too late on the other one I I I
feel that way sometimes too but what do
you hope they do get from you um I want
my kids to know about confidence I want
my kids to know there is no confidence
without discipline that it's always work
um you don't deserve is no confidence
without discipline is a great quote yeah
that's my godfather not me I'm not that
smart but uh I I tell them all the time
you don't deserve everything everything
you get is going to be what you earn and
sometimes even when you earn it you
still don't get it um that's a great
lesson by the way and that's good for
any artist out there too um so those are
like the main things that I try to teach
him cuz I want confident
kids who can take care of me when I'm
old and and won't and won't and won't
hate me I told my son I was like hey you
g to you going wipe my ass when I get
old and he D I think you made some
sacrifices that deserve a yes but you
don't deserve anything but he said he
was like No And I go why he goes I'll
hire somebody okay well that's almost
the same yeah I'm okay with that wiping
by proxy you're good what do you hope
they don't is there anything about you
you're like man I [__] hope they
don't get that um I'm
my mom would describe me when I was a
kid as a shrinking violet and uh really
yeah yeah I was very shy as a kid and I
didn't
like meeting human
beings so and my daughter takes a very
long time to warm up to a room um and
it's so me um and she wants to be alone
a lot like I wanted to be alone a lot
and I don't I didn't want that for her
but I was was happy you know what I mean
I just she has a brother you know um and
my son is the he's like he walks in a
room and he's like what's up everybody
this is the booty gun and he turns
around it's like and just sticks his ass
in every I do that
too so he takes after your side of the
family he's part of the wolf's Clan so
you know they're very opposite in in
that regard but I teach them I and this
is what I try to tell a lot of our
friends who having kids is like teach
them what you knew best so it's like for
my kids it's my daughter's been boxing
since she was four she's done Jiu-Jitsu
since she was four my son's about to
turn four he already kind of wrestles
even though I shouldn't I teach him that
um I my son was a black belt when he was
eight in what Taekwondo that's dope
stuff my godfather was a black uh more
than just a black belt in tangsudo which
was the Korean Foundation that the
Chinese version of Taekwondo was sort of
built upon so there's some cool martial
arts history is it less is is tongu do
Taekwondo always struck me as kind of a
dance no man look Taekwondo is legit but
I I'll put it this way like I have a
black belt in Taekwondo and I never lost
a Taekwondo tournament because back then
no one knew how to use their hands right
like all you had to do was step inside
and they would cover instead of punch
because their first desire their first
want is to kick because the hardest
thing to forget is the first thing you
learn and Taw teaches you how to kick
before they teach you how to punch the
first thing I learned was the jab and
that wins
so especially in the tournaments right
especially in a tournament like a point
system but in real life too you want
your jab if you don't have a jab you
really don't know how to fight you think
you do but you really don't and if you
ever fight someone who does have a jab
you going to lose ask Larry H why is
that it's the clo it's Bruce Lee would
say it's the closest part of me to you
but it's not causing a lot of damage uh
Larry Holmes could put people on their
ass with a stiff jab um ask Muhammad Ali
how that jab felt like it it's no joke
and if I'm punching you you ain't
punching me and if you are you're not
seeing me because you're seeing a jab
and that's when they come over the top
with that right hand is when you react
to that so there's something called a
faint yeah so it's like if I jab you
four or five times and it's keep popping
your head back and you can't hit me you
get mad and so when I jab you start
moving your head backwards or to the
side now I'm going to fake like I'm
going to jab it's called a faint and
when your body reacts now I'm going to
throw a punch because you can't move any
further back than you just move it truly
and that's how guys get cha fighting
truly is a chess mat the sweet science
of bruising that's what the old school
boxers would call Eddie fch would call
it that because you are you are really
at the first round or two you're trying
to you're kind of feeling them out what
their Tendencies are coell back that
failing out process you're learning
their Tendencies so then and you're
seeing what they're reacting to oh when
I step forward he steps back instead of
to the side or to the other side so now
I can throw straight punches and he's
going to run out of real estate so you
can do all these things or you say I'm
going to leave this jab a little lazy
cuz I want him to throw the overhand
right so when Hees does I can duck under
and I got his body so you're baiting
people you're doing at that level you
are like if I'm going with a real legit
guy I keep it simple if I'm going with a
guy that is around my level I'll be more
creative if they're below my level I'm
more just a teacher but like if I'm
going to spar with Tony I would have to
Tony Ferguson I'm talking about and this
dude is like w of his last nine fights
in the UFC 25% of all the DAR choke
submissions in the history of the UFC
are his what's a dar choke Dar choke is
you're taking your arm over theirs under
their neck and with your other arm
you're going over the shoulder and then
grabbing your bicep um the bicep the
bicep of the arm that goes over the
shoulder this time I'm about four
Knuckles deep Ferguson's Knuckles are
bigger than mine so 25% of all the chok
and there's a lot of them are his so
that's where I went to learn the DARS
cuz that's how I've been since I was a
kid like my God I you're going to learn
how to kick SHO is going to teach you
cuz Shuki had the in the Guinness Book
of World Records the hardest kick in the
world so he's like that's who you learn
if you're going to learn Judo you go to
Gan Lael if you're going to lose uh
learn Jiu-Jitsu you go to the machad or
you go to the Gracies and like the that
was the philosophy so when I saw Tony
like God bless you social media nobody
says that I found him on Twitter reached
out we traded numbers and the first
thing Ro he's like you're [__]
serious I thought you were joking broing
I was like yeah bro I want to come down
I was like just don't try to kill me
he's like n dog I was like cool I'll see
you in Costa Mesa I drove an hour and a
half Cruis down and and trained down
there man so all your belts what what
are your what what have you take
Taekwondo Taekwondo Tang sudo um Kempo
which no disrespect to Kempo guys it
kind of Marshal Combat Sports have
evolved beyond what kmo sort of brings
to the table so it's a black belt but I
don't really count it you black belt in
all three of those in those three yeah
and then in Jiu-Jitsu I'm a blue belt
with uh three stripes and then uh I
never belted in Judo but I trained Judo
for a long ass time uh I wrestled and do
you still have the tond flexibility yeah
oh yeah I can still get a leg up oh yeah
can you still can you drop into a split
no without
vomiting my daughter's got some sweet
splits like all almost puke
from but I'm tall so I can still kick
High you when my son was eight he got a
black belt in Taekwondo maybe nine and I
remember we were walking in the mall
over here and he for fun would walk in
the splits
he could walk in the splits and slide
down and get himself back up and slide
down and get himself back up and he
could do in the side too what kind of
tendons does this child have he can't do
it anymore there was one point in time
he's not a freak of science where I was
[__] around with him he was like T A
Time and uh I was talking [__] and I was
like don't don't make me he was someone
about cleaning his room and I was going
over the top like don't make me come in
here and make you right and I turn
around and I tell my wife I'm like and I
have to come back in here and I when I
turned around he had
just he had his foot up right where my
face was just and he had kept a perfect
pose there yeah and he was like don't
turn your back and I go good idea did
you like Neo did Mr Smith Matrix yeah
like put the kick on you and then just
showed you the foot show me the foot
that's the foot that's going to do you
in this is this your boy is this the the
foot right here this is my this is my
son Jacob man fredd this is
FR how are you you guys are still here
we're about we're we're about to hop out
we've been here for half an hour and a
half buddy n like 20 minutes 20 minutes
good to see you you good um how this is
the extended Tommy Chong 10minute
version this is my so this is the he's
taller than me dude how tall are you 6
yeah you are dude every bit of what's up
wil the still all right well we we an
hour and a half buddy we did a good it's
pretty good for my rookie sesh you did
really well the mic was here 91% of the
interview I would give you 95 oh thanks
what did I say 90 you gave yourself 91
you shot yourself a little bit I'll take
95 you're 95 um how did you it's very
relaxed was it oh man were do it again
yeah what were you I just out of
curiosity what were you expecting the
only podcasts I do are Star Wars
podcasts because I voiced that that Jedi
Canan jerus on the on the cartoon and so
everything is so Force Centric and they
like me doing those because I have like
I'll take it deep on them and be like
you know the emperor is aware of the
force sort of autocorrecting itself the
force is about balance and that's why
instead of killing Anakin which then the
force would create more balance he
seduces Anakin to double his strength
but then what does the force do it then
doubles it gives us Luke and Leia
there's balance so I'll go on those
trips and like the Star Wars Community
is like
dude oh my I never even what and they
and so those are the only ones I do so
when I speak with you it's like the only
time I can talk about something that's
not force Centric or or so now if Yoda
can get there what is the midi chorian
count do you think I'm like I four
million it's four I have no I don't even
know I will tell you but this is
different so it's good it's a nice
change I need balance here's what I love
about I I and here's why I knew I was
going to like you the text you sent me I
was like hey man you want me to come up
to your house you want to come to mine
and your text paraphrasing was you know
our house is kind of the house where the
neighborhood kids hang out that was all
I needed to know about you that tells me
that tells me so much about you dude
because and about them they're loud yes
and about them but to be the house cuz
our house was too growing up that tells
you like that's what's important oh dude
we do archery like we have this cool CER
my daughter's sick she shoots bow and
arrow catniss oh she's a pimp bro I did
when I was a kid I grew up to Mexico man
like this what you do so the kids come
over they shoot bow and arrow they swim
in the pool we throw down the Jiu-Jitsu
mats in the backyard I whoop up on them
like we have fun man there's only one
question I just want to be my godfather
that was my Godfather's house in the
valley and Tarzana on Donna and Ventura
yeah and that was their backyard and
every kid came there cuz Bob was the man
and I just want to be the man dude I got
one question for you this is the only
question I I wanted to ask you going in
because I was curious because like I
grew up and my parents are still married
oh my God my parents are still married
and they're still you know when I call
them on the phone half the if I talk to
him for 20 minutes 15 minutes of it is
them talking to each other did you take
the trash out and into the yeah I took
it out are you sure you did I'm F you
got patience you're a good my question
and this is the I only had one question
it was kind of a serious one at at what
age did you forgive your
debt because for you to be this happy
you have to have already oh yeah yeah
yeah um and and I'll start that by
saying it took a long
long time yeah um when my daughter was
born I said like all my priorities sort
of flipped right and acting wasn't even
in the top 10 it just wasn't um but you
know when I was
young and I kids who have gone through
this will relate other people might
think it's hardcore like my father's
buried at Forest Lawn in Burbank Y and I
used to book jobs and then go straight
like a Warner Brothers job or when I
have my show on Warner Brothers I would
go straight to and I would yell at him I
would cuss him out I would be mad and
pissed off that he missed out on all
these things that I was doing for him
and it's hard to realize you're chasing
a ghost in the chase yeah cuz you got
blinders on and you're so focused on
proving something I don't even know what
it was but I knew I had to prove
something so there was no forgiveness
for a long time and then right around
when I was like 34 right after my
daughter was born
I I've just like Bruce Lee would say be
water like I felt like water like I went
and I sat I sat down on the bench and I
just talked to him it wasn't the first
time we spoke you know what I mean like
I had full-on conversations with with
him where he's straight up talking back
and and that ain't crazy voices in my
head like it's just the way it goes um
and we talked and I literally said the
words and that was the first time I was
probably 34 years old was right a few
months after Charlotte was born was
there a release oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like what's the the corny way is
like the monkey off your back but when
when you're a junior like here's a
better way to describe it it wasn't so
much forgiving him I had to forgive
myself too for putting so
much putting him on so much of a
pedestal and not allowing him to be a
flawed character and so every
disappointment was like times 10 yeah
and so once I was able to forgive him I
could forgive myself for being such a
hard ass on a ghost you know what I mean
like how can a ghost say sorry like how
can a ghost be you know come back and be
like yeah man I [__] up bro like they
can't do that so once you forgive them I
was able to forgive myself and that was
peace
you you had to learn something earlier
than everybody else right now your kids
think you're a superhero oh for sure for
sure so and I asked him my son that the
other day what age did you start to look
at me as a person you never got the
superhero no man I got the worst person
like well I guess Vader would be the
worst dad you could have um well I mean
depends that's the whole it's like it's
a movie about finding your father and
then you find out who it is oh it's
Hitler like that blows man nobody wants
that I was really hoping it wasn't going
to be Hitler well like there's Hitler
pull pot and then there was me um so I
never got I got a magical version of him
but it was never super hero right
because I saw the damage that it did to
my mother I saw what a broken heart
genuinely looks like not the heart of
someone who's been cheated on okay there
are people who are still married and and
they cheat and they do what they or they
don't call it cheating sometimes or
maybe it's on the slide like that's hurt
right that can be a broken heart but he
shot himself on her
birthday and we didn't really do
birthdays cuz they were horrible like it
just was so there was no hero to me when
I first moved to to LA in 1994 I was at
his
grave three four five days a week and it
was very rare that we had a positive
conversation like even if I booked a job
it was more just so you know you missed
another one and I did great stuff in
there and it was better than what you
could do you know what I mean like there
was this sense of let me show you that
I'll take care of the woman that you
couldn't take care of and I'll never let
Mom work and I'll never you know what I
mean so there was like this iny face
kind of thing like when you're young and
you want to cost to fight for if you
don't have one you fight for the whales
or whatever green pece or you know
wherever you got to go I had a fight it
was within my own family I didn't have
to look externally for it it was
internal and and I fought and I lost for
a long time and it wasn't until it goes
back to Star Wars it wasn't until Luke
Skywalker was willing to not fight that
he's able to beat Vader and when I
stopped having anger and when I stopped
trying to fight a ghost everything was
chill man peace bro nice to meet you
nice to meet you too bud love you thanks
bro where where you going hang out this
house for a little bit you going to hang
out of his house yeah you two by the way
may have the palest legs combination so
congratulations look at the your legs Oh
my legs are so white they're like a
light blue but I feel like if they took
their shirts off I could see their
organs actually operating beneath the
skin yeah I can actually see your liver
glowing through the
shirt see you love you all right sorry
for talking trash on your side
you started it I always talk trash all
right good he's I already talk trash to
my four-year-old like think you could do
that scrub boom when he picks me up and
like you know my nickname for anybody
picks me up since we're Jewish I call
him my Juber so I'll call him on the
phone if I need a ride I'm like Juber
come get me at the airport he's like can
you call me by my name I just did I just
did that's so Boston right there I just
did I just called you Juber didn't you
hear me uh it's fascina what I said
that's what you
are dude I'm I'm I'm I'm uh here's
one of the things and and we're going to
get out of here but one of the messages
that I love about my podcast is that I
love people I I'm always interested in
to hear how what people's hardships were
and how what their Journey was to
overcome yeah because I think for people
who are living outside of our business
who think oh they [__] they had a
silver spoon or their life was easy or
it's not it's it's important for
everybody in all walks of life to hear
you have choices and everybody's life is
hard sucked we got kicked out of our
house like it wasn't easy you could have
taken a different path dude for sure you
could be a a drug addict for sure and
angry still right now in Albuquerque
there's plenty of that plenty of that
right so everyone saw breaking
bad yeah you know that
house dude you choices bro yeah yeah man
but I had a good support group around me
a lot of guys that don't have a father
you know the the preacher on Sunday is
in enough man you need somebody who lets
you in their house you can see how they
treat their wife you can see how they
treat their children and then that gives
you aspirational Vibes a lot of guys
don't get that man and so in that regard
I was I was you know more fortunate than
than some of my peers but in other ways
it was way worse cuz when everyone knows
your dad and then they're dead and the
way they died is not a cool way um you
know that's the flip side of that it's
like yeah your dad died in jail but
everybody knows how my dad died and they
want to talk to me about it every day
and I'm 20 [__] three years old like
I did a Jim Rome interview back when he
was on like Fox back in the day like
1996 and the first question out of his
mouth was hey have you ever thought
about committing suicide like your
father and it's like what a that's a
dick and like to me I'm I'm like wow if
we were in the same room I'm 24 okay I
still had a lot of anger yeah and I had
a lot of fights under my belt and if we'
have been in the same room
hea got hurt like that was not the right
age for me to be dealing with that type
of an unprofessional question you see on
your face have you seen that interview
oh yeah and I know sell it right like I
try to be Andre right and I'm like no no
no I never I never would think about
that kind of stuff and that's not really
who I am and I'm trying to kind of like
educate through kindness but in my head
like the whole time I'm like I think
this motherfucker's in Southern
California and I got to find out where
this studio is like that was the only
and I've and I've met and I've seen
but I him that I was likeo man we been
in the same like You' have gone to sleep
it wouldn't have been ever back in the
day when he was doing things to get
ratings The Jim Everett stuff and all
and I told him that we were we were at
uh what's the oh what is that place
called I'm Ina Boulevard they got no
they got the lavash press and it's like
right next to alte Cafe I used to eat
there all the time and that's where I
ran take Cafe down in Studio City yeah
in Studio City it's like a little yellow
sign yeah where the the breakfast place
yeah what's it called I start with an m
not Marabella no it's like Mambo chambo
but they got some [__] great
breakfast pot man breakfast potatoes
that breakfast sandwich is Bomb so
that's where we talked it out and had it
there and it was like oh I didn't mean
any disrespect and like whether he did
or not was irrelevant I was just trying
to have a conversation like get that off
my chest um but yeah man that stuff used
to like wreck me I couldn't even talk
about it like as a kid you go to like my
mom you know you know she did everything
she could she sent me to like Counseling
group counseling and I would see
everyone talk and my face would get
redder and as and like you feel pressure
dog it like worse than going up on a
talent show you know what I mean like
and you have to follow the guy that
juggles real sick you're like [__] I got
jokes follow the guitar hat like it's
it's rough man and so then it would come
to me and I wouldn't say anything and
then the shrink would just say the word
father and I would up and bounce like I
couldn't even cuz I would be mad at the
doctor for embarrassing me and I want to
punch him out and that's a grown man and
you can't as a kid beat up a grown man
that'll wreck someone's life you can so
you can but you're not supposed to
that's a Mike Tyson [__] right there
well I ain't M I ain't made Iron either
but uh but yeah man so it was real real
hard but like with anything the more you
do it the easier it gets or you can fake
it till you make it and then one day it
slaps you in the face and you either let
it go or you lose and I was able to let
it go based on you know the the lessons
that I've learned not everybody can do
that and it sucks but that's the that's
the the the balls that life throws at
you man on a side note yeah a good
breakfast sandwich is just about the
best thing anybody if you make some
tobasco sauce to make a good breakfast
sandwich is hard to beat as something
off of a menu in that place what is it
called [__] when I'm driving home I'm
going to be
like I'll text it to you um can't
believe I forgot dude do you want to
plug anything um yeah man I wrote a
really cool cookbook that's gotten great
reviews and great word of mouth and
people keep hitting me up and showing me
recipes that my mom made for me as a kid
that that chefs in really cool
restaurants all around the world made
for me and it's kind of my take on them
and you can get it online if you want at
back Toth kitchen book.com or just go to
Barnes & Noble man they've they've
showed me a lot of love and and they dig
the book and there's a lot of podcast
stories in there I don't want to just
write a cookbook no so every recipe kind
of has a a story like the ones I've been
telling telling you I think I even tell
the story where Chuck Norris broke my
rib in the book what yeah Chuck you
sparred with him when I was 15 I told
you I W A bunch of taond tournaments and
I won a national one and got a really
cool trophy that was taller than me and
my godfather goes oh his best friend's
Chuck Norris they lived four houses away
from each other and Donna they behaved
like Frat Boys for like 20 years and
would go to UCLA and like beat up
linebackers and like start fights I'm
not joking so he goes oh you think
you're hot [__] I'm like yeah man I'm
[__] killing it you know I'm 15
testost flowing he goes oh you want to
Sparrow Chuck I'm like and I literally
go yeah let me show Chuck what I can do
oh no how old was Chuck at the time um
probably close to 40 I was 15 so that's
probably yeah probably close to 40 so we
walked to his house um and my godfather
had this great El Camino with like a
like a 408 in it some beast that's not a
real engine but it was huge and he
wouldn't even let us go there cuz he's
like no it's too close we walk down
there and we go into his little dojo in
the backyard um he doesn't live there
anymore anymore so if you want to see
where he used to live it's on Donna
Street it's really cool house um and we
go in this little dojo and like you were
saying with that girl I threw my jab out
cuz my Jabs butter right and that's what
won me that tournament and I throw it
out
there and he's kind of just moving and
being cool he does not want to hurt me
he's a nice nice kind Man Who Loved Me
and showed me love for was a little bo
blows at him oh yeah I'm I'm trying to
oh 100 like what's beyond that it's
Chuck Norris dude you're going to your
best yes I get it so I want to look as
money as I can look and and doing like
three Jabs right and he's just like you
know being nice and respectful and then
I get cocky and I try to do it again
like you can throw three Jabs on a guy
three times in a row in real life let
alone Chuck [__] Norris and so I do
it again and he just throws one wheel
kick and he doesn't try to hurt me he's
pulling the kick and he hits me right in
the he's a big dude he wasn't that big
like I'm taller than he was then now
like he was like 510 W maybe I just
remember him opposite Bruce he wasn't
that much bigger than Bruce um so he
throws one wheel kick and it hits me in
What's called the floating rib and it
broke it and I hit the ground and
there's a great Richard PRI joke where
he says you ever have air just leave
your lungs like air just says [__]
it so I hit the ground and all I could
say was get breath like when you lose
your breath which is what my godfather
and he's laughing but he's like like he
the funniest in the world and I'm down
and truck's like oh my God I'm so sorry
I'm like and truck and my Godfather's
like oh he's fine don't [__] worry
about a truck that's a great lesson I'll
see you tonight like it's nothing we're
walking home I'm like doubled over
leaning as hard left as I can cuz
anything upright feels like there's a
chainsaw cutting through my body we go
inside I finally like break down it's
too much pain and I'm kind of crying and
my godmother Lillian comes in um my
Godfather's 61 big tough guy Thin
Mustache try to make fun of it um he'll
he'd Rock a mullet if he wanted to
nothing anybody could do my 5 foot one
Godmother is Italian and does not [__]
around and literally goes what Bob what
did you do to it what did you do he goes
I Didn't Do It Chuck [__] hurt him
and she goes what's WR I go I think I
broke my rib and he goes yeah he
probably did it's the first thing he
says and not to take me to the hospital
and my godmother goes we can't send him
home like Bob Kathy will Kathy will
shoot you she will shoot you and she
would have I told you before like she
around I saw her pull a gun in a in a
parking lot when a guy tried to mug her
and she pulled her gun out of yeah she
pulled her gun out of a purse instead of
her wallet the GU whiter than your son's
legs and ran for the hills bro so I got
to stay in California for three extra
weeks um and got to miss the whole first
week of school cuz Chuck Norris broke
your rib yeah and I didn't tell my mom
till I was like 25 and when I finally
told her and I was like yeah lilan
freaked out you would have shot B she's
like I [__] want to shot it I didn't
give a crap okay I got one more question
now that we brought up Czech Norris and
Bruce Lee oh yeah I mean this all the
age-old question who wins that fight
Bruce no doubt Bruce why just speed no
man Bruce was to martial arts what
LeBron was to is to basketball what what
Serena Williams was to tennis he was
this hybrid that didn't believe in in
one style and he was the one who taught
Chuck to sort of accept and embrace that
philosophy to the point where Chuck
brought the entire masado family with
him to Texas when he was doing Walker
Texas Ranger to embrace Jiu-Jitsu and
used them all as stuntmen to beat up on
his show like really and that was
Bruce's philosophy of of expanding and
not not being a master of of one being a
master of all um and I think in that
movie Chuck did the job to steal a
wrestling term but it was to show that
out of respect this dude's the best
right and if Chuck's saying that but he
never came out but that's what I'm
saying like that's why I think he showed
it there and he's passing like he didn't
have to do that he didn't have to do
that scene he didn't have to let Bruce
snatch a bald spot of hair out of his
chest hair like he didn't have to lose
that fight he could have said no thanks
but he did and he did that because I
think he respected what Bruce brought to
the table as a martial artist you this
is a guy my godfather would be in China
with him and guys would challenge Bruce
on the street straight up because movie
studi said if you can beat Bruce Lee in
a fight we'll give you a three- picture
deal this was to fight the street guys
walk straight up to him they would tap
their they would cross their arms and
tap their feet three times and Bruce
literally would be in midc conversation
with my godf be like I'll be right back
whip the [__] out of that guy come back
and go let's go get some lunch stop it
and that's legit dude that's there's
other people who hung with Bruce will
tell you the same [__] story that's
how hardcore he was and when he left his
deal with China they were pissed I don't
remember the name of the film company
that he sign so that's how they
challenged him to a fight and he would
just beat people up on the street and
then walk back away and then bounce and
leave and then eventually just came to
[__] LA and was like [__] all that
man it's crazy everybody wants to
[__] kill my ass that's insane that's
why when he passed away some people like
tried to say it was an inside job and
things like that you know and then all
the conspiracy theories because there
was so much of that movie Studio's hate
of Bruce leaving them because he was
their first like uber star you know he
became International like Sunny chibe
ain't got [__] on Bruce Lee D I love
Sunny Chiba you know what I'm saying but
like it's not the same thing that's a
[__] great story Yeah man so he was
the real deal he wasn't just a movie man
like he would have beat Kareem Abdul
jabbar's ass Kareem learned from Bruce
Bruce didn't learn from Kareem I also
think that when you're 72 you can see
kicks and punches coming a little easier
yeah but when you're 72 you know how
much time Bruce has to react big ass
okay I thought you put on you can see it
oh yeah he's like no I'm way over
here so you're that big arm is reaching
back now so it's going to come forward
Michael Thompson who backed Kareem up
for the Lakers uh he's Clay Thompson's
uh daddy I've done his radio show a
couple times he he was best friends with
Kareem he always gets mad at me when I
say he's like Kareem because you can't
say nothing against Kareem right
Kareem's the best at he's like Kareem
would have killed Bruce Lee I'm like
Michael he's like I could beat Bruce Lee
I'm like Michael you could Bruce Lee's
dead he'd beat you up if you went to his
grave can I tell you something I what I
want to do and when I know people like
so he loves Kem yeah my whole goal when
I go on shows like that wrestleing I
know I would Kevin
mcale okay Michael Michael had to guard
Kevin M Kevin mcale and Michael Thompson
played basketball on the same team in
Minnesota together and then had to play
again and Michael always like oh I hated
that guy more than they love each other
but when I know stuff like that oh that
would I have three older brothers so my
what's more fun for me is just to argue
the opposite yeah it's more fun to go on
show you get him with a male oh i' hit
him with a male or even a Robert Parish
oh well no that one won't get him as hot
cuz he he has the more respect for I hit
him with a M and be like you know what
you know who's better than Kem is M oh
he would he might hit you he might hit
I'm filling in for him tomorrow on on
ESPN and if they like me and if I do a
good job and I I get a regular gig there
I got to bring you in when Michael's
there just so we can have a Kevin Mel
debate and let me tell you something
else please come back and do this
because dude uh like I said I knew from
the text that I would like you but you
I'm I'm All About positive energy dude
you I can tell man from your wall of
photos I know what you're all about and
I know that you're about making people's
lives better regardless of of of the
level of better um and that's that's
super cool like I follow you dude I see
how you deal with people I see how you
deal with humans whether they're they're
good or bad or just trying to survive
and and I like that Vibe so that's why
that's why I'm here man it's easy I
appreciate it man and guys I'm going to
be I don't know what the date
is it's your highw walk I know it's
Monday August 15th I'm going to be in St
Louis this weekend
I and it's going to be
127° so get to the club cuz there's air
conditioning yeah get inside it's sticky
sexis and everybody all right oh I took
a pro wrestling move in St Louis I took
a back breaker in St Louis from Randy
Orton how'd that go not good that's a
big dude and by the way like he
protected me and took care of me in the
next day I wouldn't have been wrestling
I was like dude you do this 340 days a
year dude that's why they deserve all
the respect in two weeks of sleep
ridiculous I literally was like my
[__] neck yeah I would have a I would
have a different bowl of
weedies all right guys love you we'll
talk to you later peace buddies
buddies buddies buddies buddies buddies
buddies buddies
buddies buddies buddies Buddies